so many dumb ways to die oh hey I didn't
see it
welcome to dumb ways to die I'm sure
you've seen the video everyone's seen
the video at this point but they're also
having a really awesome iPhone game or I
find hopes oh yeah it's really funny
it's really awesome and I wanted to show
it to you breasts so here we go way to
show off your money man
[Music]
enough chitchat let's play duck oh hey
I'll know [ __ ] why would you poke a bee
right
ha that's why you [ __ ] beer hello the
music oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] don't don't let
him fall oh come on stop it one okay
this gave it too fast for me to [ __ ]
talk over defend the private parts
don't eat my penis
thank you are always showing on he's
like noon you want my badge don't so
tempting much faster okay
Oh No
okay there we go no no god damn it fast
Oh God okay because I'm special
No
[Music]
well done you unlock a new character who
is it what a character
this is my favorite all right let's try
this [ __ ] again Oh God
[ __ ] did you eat its claim you're
welcome 10 X or points for a smiley face
thank you
stop your god I hate this one like I
don't have enough fingers oh that's a
horrible maybe if you stop jiggling your
junk
we wouldn't be in this situation I don't
have more dicks
what happened points for style oh yeah
[Music]
don't kill yourself I have to be fast as
[ __ ] go away go away go away go away
I have spit all over my screen er oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yes come on baby
why don't you - behind that's [ __ ]
clean
all right let's do it again I love this
one it's really hard
did you eat Ballu and that's oh [ __ ]
what is this go away oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] don't don't you ever say I will
till done Oh mm baby come on baby
I do have that many fingers thank you
Hey I guess stress okay I'm not good and
just straight up kitchen 3080 never mind
nail that because I was special what
happens if I click of course of course
all right so that's a really fun game
there's another game that you brought
[Music]
now my girlfriend I've been playing this
a little bit I kind of know what it's
about but I actually never played it
myself so here we go okay that went
great
oh I got it there we go
this is probably gonna take a while
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I got no here we go
baby
yeah we good
oh my god no I was so happy I'm not
leaving until I beat my god that sounded
really bad [ __ ] why don't you just fly
like a normal [ __ ] bird how about
that have you tried that how about you
how about you just change your name to
[ __ ] flying bird and we wouldn't have
this problem right he's flying fine now
now he's fine but when I play he's like
I'm not flat and hit [ __ ] everything
you ruined my life flappy you ruined my
[ __ ] life what's with those lips
birds don't have lips those [ __ ] lips
are bigger than Mickey Minaj [ __ ] ass
why can't I get two [ __ ] six this
[ __ ] game is a [ __ ] it does not
make that sound if you hit your eye into
something I'm just one okay yes flap
your ass off you little [ __ ] it's just
a [ __ ] kids game where you get to
work that your buddy is really flappy
flipper I think you and I are gonna go
well together I really your piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hope you died it is a
bird it's called flappy bird but he has
[ __ ] lips or maybe that's something
else I could be a vagina if you pull it
this way
that would make a lot of more sense okay
this [ __ ] make it to seven okay
how the [ __ ] did she make it to six I
don't understand my parents I made it to
100 well that's so great lad flappy you
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay Kenny
canoeing can you're a canoeing bird okay
that's what I was gonna say thanks for
suggesting this game I now understand
why your dicks it's not even [ __ ]
hard look at this [ __ ]
look at dis ah don't even talk to me
and les you're famous you piece of [ __ ]
why are you such a [ __ ] atrocity I
hope you die you lip don't penis stain
in my vagina I will [ __ ] you out 13
bitching alpha
both so the trick is to scream out bad
things while you do this piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hope you [ __ ] die your
lips look like they are [ __ ] oh my
god I'm on a roll [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Hey
look at me now haters god yep
oh my god you later cunning cannoli
kanui I said canoeing I promise I
promise you don't know what I you don't
know what I think okay okay I have to
say this game is a lot harder than in
[ __ ] legs what it even hit replay
replay it didn't it didn't it didn't it
I think we all had that I've thought
about [ __ ] a fish in the mouth before
but with this game I want to do it more
than ever
Oh
d Japs [ __ ] you in the [ __ ] mouth I
[ __ ] hate flappy same flat before you
never flap this bit a bit before pretty
by 2013 see once you get on a roll you
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] just like real life
just do jab like you rub fun quarreling
[Music]
everybody is flappy Shalala everybody is
flappy Shalala did you just [ __ ] pee
on my couch you little [ __ ]
[Music]
well I'm too busy playing flappy anyway
[ __ ] my life
please just let me go to [ __ ] 13 oh
my god
hope you enjoy this episode I like if
you're dead you better I'm coming for ya
look at that [ __ ] metal all shiny and
[ __ ] just like you my ass it's the sky
comrade a zebras tomorrow with the
proper [ __ ] video and none of this
[ __ ] iOS [ __ ] thousand breast
Lobby
[Music]